Transcription: Anaelle Fécil
Relecteur: eric vautier
Alors, alors...
Vous m'entendez bien?
Public : Oui!
exXÒs mètKakOla: Si je vous dis...
Antillais.
Musique.
Vous répondez quoi?
Public : Zouk.
(Musique)
(Le public tape dans les mains)
exXÒs: Plus fort, plus fort, ingénieur.
(Le volume augmente)
(La musique s'arrête)
Si je vous dis qu'on regarde un film,
blockbuster,
grosse prod.
Il y a un personnage caribéen -
en général, c'est un Jamaïcain.
En général, il a des cheveux longs
ou il fait du reggae.
C'est bien,
mais tout ça n'est-il pas
un peu réducteur?
Si je vous disais que cette région,
la Caraïbe,
est la plus riche musicalement
dans le monde?
Oui, oui, la Caraïbe.
Avec plus d'une vingtaine
de styles de musique créés ici,
d'antan lontan jusqu'à maintenant.
Je ne vais pas tous les énumérer,
mais on a: rumba, mambo,
cha-cha-cha, salsa, sound,
merengue, calypso, mento,
rub-a-dub, reggae.
On a la biguine, on a le jazz créole.
On a le gwoka.
On a le bel air.
Là, je pense que je suis déjà arrivé
à une quinzaine.
Pourtant,
Antillais = zouk.
(Rires)
Alors, moi-même ne suis pas un enfant
d'une famille de musiciens,
comme certaines superstars.
Pourtant, grâce à ma mère et à mon père,
j'ai découvert et apprécié:
Jacques Brel, Brassens,
Mozart, Tchaïkovsky, Lynch, Tito Puente,
James Brown...
Et, moi-même ado,
fan inconditionnel de Prince,
prince du rock.
Pourtant, Antillais = zouk.
Alors, c'est vrai qu'on me demande:
« Quelle musique joues-tu ? »
Euh, là je bugge.
On me demande:
« Mais, quel instrument joues-tu ?
Tu nous dis que t'es musicien.»
Un peu de tout mais pas vraiment,
je bugge.
Vous allez comprendre pourquoi.
De là d'où je viens, la Guadeloupe,
la musique de mes aînés
ressemble à ça :
(Instrumental de gwoka)
(La musique s'arrête)
Rien à voir.
Mais, c'est de chez nous.
Imaginez-vous que ce qui me ramène,
dans ma vie,
à la musique de chez moi,
c'est cette musique-là:
(Instrumental de hip-hop)
Etc., hein.
(La musique s'arrête)
Aux antipodes.
Je peux vous dire
que depuis que je suis jeune,
j'entends toujours le même combat -
débat, ça dépend -
qui oppose
le «(Créole guadeloupéen) yo kont nou».
Traduction: le «eux contre nous»
et vice versa.
Combat sempiternel, ainsi qu'un autre:
le truc des jeunes
contre le truc des vieux,
les vieux... le truc des jeunes
contre le truc des vieux.
Alors, comment faire?
Je pense à une anecdote très récente.
Mon ami Star Jee, qui fait partie
de mon groupe de rap,
disait récemment dans un magazine
que quand il avait 15 ans,
il s'est rendu à l'île de la Trinidad
en voyage organisé,
en famille d'accueil,
et la maman de cette famille
disait de son fils devant mon ami:
«Il n'écoute
que de la musique étrangère!
De la musique jamaïcaine ! »
Comme quoi, ce n'est pas
qu'un combat-débat qui ne vient que d'ici.
Et on retrouve à chaque fois
la même problématique:
«eux contre nous»,
« le truc des vieux
contre le truc des jeunes ».
Alors, j'ai envie de dire:
comment aller plus loin?
Comment faire en sorte que ce jeune,
quel que soit d'où il vient,
puisse autant s'approprier
la musique de chez lui
que les musiques et tendances actuelles
qu'il affectionne tant?
Comment ?
Et, j'irais plus loin:
comment, nous-mêmes,
apporter notre contribution
à l'héritage culturel de ce monde
sans se délaver,
sans perdre son identité,
sa couleur, ses valeurs ?
Alors au tout début,
avec mon groupe de rap, le Karukéra Crew,
tout ce que nous voulions faire,
c'était du rap.
Première difficulté,
face à nos familles,
notre peuple, nos gens :
«Qu'est-ce que vous faites là?»
« Vous singez les Américains. »
«On a nos trucs chez nous.», etc.
Peut-être qu'on voulait que je fasse
de la biguine ou du gwoka,
mais je n'étais pas né là-dedans.
Au fur et à mesure, très naturellement
et avec beaucoup de passion,
nous avons commencé
à créoliser notre hip-hop.
Nous avons commencé à changer
la musique et nos paroles.
On a abandonné le français.
Pardon pour la langue dominante,
comme dit TiMalo,
mais nous avons dévoré le créole,
les dictionnaires de créole,
les livres créoles, la poésie créole,
les paraboles, les métaphores.
Deuxième difficulté
pour notre rap créolisé:
comme tout musicien et chanteur,
on a besoin d'un producteur,
de financement.
Il faut trouver un producteur.
En Guadeloupe,
il n'y en avait pas beaucoup
et nous sommes allés,
comme beaucoup de gens,
en France, à Paris,
pour trouver un producteur.
Un producteur qui accepterait de miser
sur un son en créole,
avec des paroles en créole,
avec un swing créole,
comme la doudou de chez nous.
Mission impossible.
On avait une difficulté [du fait
qu'on n'était] pas dans le truc national.
Nous ne chantons pas en français
et nous ne faisons pas de la musique
vraiment américaine, finalement.
Troisième difficulté...
Attention, à la deuxième difficulté,
nous avons bûché,
nous sommes devenus autoproducteurs.
Tout le monde
n'a pas la faculté, le talent,
d'être chef d'entreprise et producteur,
mais comme il n'y avait pas de producteur,
nous nous sommes autoproduits.
Je reviens sur la troisième difficulté.
Sachez que dans toutes ces machines,
ces instruments électroniques
pour composer, pour créer,
il y a des centaines,
des milliers de sonorités -
«ping» «pong» «pong» -
des milliers,
des régions du monde entier.
Il y a bien sûr des violons, des pianos,
des guitares, mais en percu,
il y a des percus d'Inde - tabla.
Il y a des djembés d'Afrique,
du Nord, du Sud, de l'Ouest.
Il y a, depuis longtemps, le congas,
de la salsa, de la musique latine.
Musique antillaise, instruments? Zéro.
Donc, la troisième difficulté, c'était:
«Je veux vous faire un son
avec ces instruments-là,
mais cette bibliothèque sonore
n'existe pas.»
Donc, je me suis assis,
j'ai bûché mon sujet,
j'ai rencontré des musiciens,
j'ai échantillonné,
car la musique électronique est faite
à partir de bouts de plein de choses
qui donnent à la fin un truc artistique.
Donc, j'ai échantillonné:
«boum», «pang»,
«ping», «pong», «pang»,
«tss tss», «touc», «tch tch».
Et, exemple, ça donnerait...
(Échantillons de percussions)
(Fin des percussions)
Tout ça, ce sont nos trucs antillais.
Un ti-bois de Martinique,
un boula, un ka.
Je ne vous ai pas tout sorti,
mais il y a les chachas,
les triangles, les cloches.
Donc, j'ai répondu
à ma troisième difficulté à l'époque,
j'ai commencé à créer
ma propre bibliothèque d'échantillons,
car les machines permettent de remplacer
ce qu'on vous donne
par ce que vous voulez.
Problème plus ou moins résolu.
Après, nous avions un autre challenge.
Oui, oui, oui, nous avions
un autre challenge.
C'est que grâce à ce hip-hop,
une fois que j'ai eu tous ces éléments,
j'ai commencé à bûcher,
parce que je ne suis pas né dans le gwoka.
Je suis un enfant de la ville.
Même si ma mère
m'envoyait dans des léwoz -
ces grandes réunions de gwoka -
je ne suis pas un enfant de musiciens
et je ne connais pas le gwoka.
Donc, les machines sont bien,
mais il a fallu bûcher le sujet.
Il a fallu rentrer dans notre patrimoine,
apprendre les leçons
que je n'avais jamais apprises.
Ça m'a pris des années
et j'ai fait mes recherches
comme un grand.
Alors, rendez-vous compte
que grâce au hip-hop,
cette musique électronique,
ce hip-hop, cette culture -
pas juste la musique rap -
la culture qui vient de la rue,
la culture du débrouillardisme,
du « fais avec ce que t'as »,
la culture du «do it yourself»
« tu vas le faire toi-même »,
ainsi que la culture du «where
are you from?»- « d'où tu viens? »
Tout ce chemin m'a permis
de revenir sur ma base.
Mais, d'où je viens?
C'est de la Guadeloupe, des Antilles.
Toute cette culture hip-hop
m'a permis de faire ce chemin
et de revenir à moi-même
et à ce moment,
j'ai fait ma propre révolution,
ma renaissance:
l'exXÒs de l'époque
s'est appelé mètKakOla,
car j'ai créé une fusion
et je lui ai donné un nom,
c'était « kako », le cacao- chocolat.
Parce que le chocolat
est aussi en créole la couleur marron,
et le marron est aussi
cet être désenchaîné qui fuit,
qui prend sa liberté
et qui existe pour lui-même.
Tout ça grâce au hip-hop
et à mon héritage familial et de mon pays.
Donc,
en fait, cette fusion que j'ai travaillée,
c'est ma révolution,
mais elle a connu aussi -
je ne sais pas si j'en suis sorti -
mais elle a connu les mêmes étapes
que cite le grand scientifique,
Idriss Aberkane :
«Toute révolution passe
par ces trois phases.
Premièrement:
'C'est ridicule !'
Deuxièmement:
'Ouah, c'est dangereux.'
Troisièmement:
'Mais, c'est évident !' »
Et il prend de super exemples
pour parler de ça:
le droit de vote des femmes, etc.;
que d'autres révolutions
sont passées aussi par les mêmes étapes.
Donc, moi je suis arrivé à mon tournant...
À ce moment-là, je renais
et je commence à faire une musique
qui me ressemble.
Une musique aussi que je voulais entendre.
Et, à travers mes recherches,
j'ai bien réalisé
qu'il n'y avait pas que la musique
dont il s'agit, en fusion.
L'artisanat,
la mode,
tout ça était en fusion
et ça re-balance un peu sur des talks
que vous avez entendus
dans la soirée avant,
sur «Le pays rêvé, le pays réel».
Pour moi, j'étais dans ma réalité.
Le défaut d'avant est devenu mon atout.
Et grâce à cet esprit,
j'ai réussi à dépasser
les tabous que j'avais.
Exemple, dans ma musique de chez moi:
«Ne la touche pas.
Tu dois la danser comme elle est,
la faire comme elle est.»
Tous ces tabous,
toutes ces barrières ont disparu.
Et j'en prends pour preuves
trois exemples.
Le premier, c'est une longue entrevue
avec des membres fondateurs de Kassav.
On en revient au zouk.
Et en fait,
eux-mêmes m'apprennent
que leur démarche était la même
que la mienne il y a quarante ans.
Ils voulaient créer un truc nouveau
pour contrebalancer
toutes les musiques étrangères
qui jouaient dans ce pays,
et ils se sont mis ensemble,
ils ont travaillé, ils ont bûché.
Et aujourd'hui,
vous voyez ce que ça a donné: le zouk.
Ouais, c'était ridicule, à un moment,
ça a été dangereux et là, c'est évident.
Deuxième exemple des preuves
qui m'ont conforté dans mon chemin.
Un événement qui date déjà
de 13 ans à peu près ou 15
et qui s'appelle «Dub N'Ka».
«Dub» et «Ka»,
créé par un des membres
fondateurs du groupe célèbre Akiyo.
Alors, cet événement réunissait
les parrains du gwoka,
les mythes fondateurs du gwoka
toujours vivants,
ainsi que les têtes de file
de la musique urbaine.
Reggae dancehall, rap -
nous tous, on était dans le même panier.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Cet événement a été marquant.
Il n'y avait aucun tabou,
aucune barrière entre nous.
Nos anciens du gwoka nous parlaient
comme des grands frères et des cousins.
Tous les secrets et les mythes du gwoka,
ils nous les dévoilaient.
Et eux-mêmes ont appris de nous.
On a vu des chanteurs de gwoka
lever les pieds, danser à la manière
de chanteurs de reggae dancehall
et dans les coulisses,
les autres disaient:
«Ouah, regardez untel!»
Parce que c'est l'énergie du jeune
qui était transfusée
dans celle de notre ancien
et nous, les jeunes, on en apprenait.
Ça, c'est un événement marquant
qui m'a montré que j'étais
dans la bonne direction.
Alors, en fait,
dans ce métissage qui est le nôtre,
dans cette créolité,
il y a les réponses
à beaucoup de problématiques
de notre société :
l'héritage à transmettre;
il y a les réponses aussi
du savoir vivre ensemble,
- nous en sommes la preuve-
il y a les réponses aussi
de la pertinence:
qu'est-ce que vous apportez
de pertinent au monde
si vous faites exactement
ce qu'il faisait déjà?
Il faut amener votre truc.
Alors, vraiment profondément,
d'expérience,
vous pouvez me croire,
la tradition n'est pas
l'ennemie de la modernité.
La modernité a besoin de la tradition.
(Applaudissements)